GOOD MORNING
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING. TO START I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THAT
HAVE MADE OUR RETURN TO THE
CAPITAL TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE.
DUE TO THE CURRENT STE CURRENT
STAYED HOME ORDER YOU'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM HERE AND FORTY TWO OH TWO.
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENTS
OF STUFF. AND A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN OUR SIX FOOT SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICTPHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR YOU MAY RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BE TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE. FROM OUTSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM OF THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT. FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES
WE ALSO WILL BE USING A
MODERATE MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. REPEAT THAT NUMBER.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON BEGINS THEIR
BILL PRESENTATIONS. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WE GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE A
PLACE IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
COMMUTING OR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO RESERVE REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MERE
WITNESS. PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL YOUR
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATE A PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL OUR COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE THREE NINE FIVE EIGHT
MY STUFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. HELLO I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
LOCAL COMMIT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE PLAY IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT WE
ALL FACE. I WANT TO YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO GO OVER
BEFORE WE START. WE HAVE TEN
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY FOUR
OF THOSE ITEMS ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. OUR CONSECUTIVE YEAR
IT CONSISTS OF THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS. ITEM ONE AB TWENTY FORTY
BIGELOW. ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY TWO GRAY.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THE SERIAL. ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ AND GRAY. WE ALSO
HAVE TO AUTHORS WHO ARE UNABLE
TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS HERE
WITH US TODAY. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
QUIRK WILL BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WICKS WILL BE
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. WE WILL BE
HEARING BILLS IN THE ORDER
SHOWN ON OUR AGENDA. WE WILL
TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OR
WITH CAN SINCE GOV WITH
CONCERNS. THESE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION HAS A POSITION ON
THE BILL. ONLY. SECRETARY OF WE
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE I RECORD HERE
LACKEY LACKEY HERE BLOOM BLOOM
HERE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RAMOS%
RAMOS HERE THREE OF US
THREE OF US HERE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL YOUR
VOEPEL HERE. THANK YOU
SECRETARY HAVE A QUORUM. OUR
FIRST BILL THIS UP THIS MORNING
IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA. YOU. SURE THAT WOULD BE
FINE IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE MISTER GREG
GOING PERSON BUT. WE ARE GOING
TO GO OUT OF ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER GRAY. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO ITEM NUMBER. I DON'T
NUMBER THIS IS FOR THANK YOU I
A. B. THIRTY THREE TWELVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY. AND
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS- AND
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
ALLOWED ME TO GO OUT OF ORDER
AND GET BACK TO GOVERNOR
ORGANIZATION. I THINK COMMITTEE
AT NOW CIS DOES A FANTASTIC JOB
OF PUTTING THIS BILL IN
CONTEXT. THE ANALYSIS NOTES
THAT THE LAW. GENERALLY
REQUIRES CITY ANNEXATIONS TO BE
CONTIGUOUS AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NEVER
JUDICIOUS. ABOUT AUTHORIZING
EXEMPTIONS FROM THAT RULE WITH
THE LAST NOTED EXEMPTION
APPROVED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOR
THE CITY OF CARP CUPERTINO. THE
NOW SAYS ASK MEMBERS CONSIDER
IF THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES FACING
THE CITY OF MERCED UC MERCED
WARRANT ONE OF THOSE RARE
EXCEPTIONS. I BELIEVE I HOPE%
YOU'LL AGREE- AN EXEMPTION IS
WARRANTED YOU SEE MERCED IS THE
YOUNGEST CAMPUS THE UC SYSTEM
WHICH IS BASED CHALLENGES TO
ITS GROWTH SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
THE GREAT RECESSION JUST STRUCK
JUST AS THE CAMPUS WAS
LAUNCHING FORCED YOU SEE MERCED
TO TURN TO PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS TO GROW AS
PROMISED. WORKING IN A FUNDING
DRIED UP OKAY THANK YOU.
CONTINUE ALL PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
I. HEARING NOTHING FOR THE
CAMPUS- WAS CITED THREE MILES
FROM THE NEAREST COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT WITH ANTICIPATION
THE DEVELOPMENT WOULD OCCUR
AROUND THE CAMPUS TO WRITE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES LIKE OFF
CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING FOOD AND
GROCERY OPTIONS IN AFFORDABLE
TRANSPORTATION. AS THE CAMPUS
NEARS ITS TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY
AND HAS NOW ENROLLED TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS THOSE
ANTICIPATED COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENTS HAVE NOT YET
OCCURRED. THIS IS A UNIQUE
SITUATION FACED BY NO OTHER
CAMPUS IN THE UC SYSTEM.
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES THE
STATE'S MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT UC MERCED HAS BY ALL
ACCOUNTS PROVED A MASSIVE
SUCCESS. THE MERCED IS THE MOST
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE CAMPUS IN THE UC SYSTEM.
AS A MAJORITY MINORITY CAMPUS
MORE THAN 70% OF STUDENTS ARE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE. AND A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH AT HOME. USED TO
MERCED HAS ALSO ROLLED THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF UN
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS IN THE UC
SYSTEM. AND THE CAMPUS HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED BOTH AS A HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTION AND AN
ASIAN AMERICAN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
SERVING INSTITUTION. UC MERCED
IS DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT. BUT
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE GROWING
PAINS. AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE
IS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE AN ERROR
EXEMPTION TO CURRENT LAW AND
ATTEMPT TO SUPPORT THE CAMPUS'S
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT. INCLUDING
PREPARATIONS TO ESTABLISH A
MEDICAL SCHOOL UC MERCED AT
UCSF FRESNO. THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW ALLISTER- EMPHASIZE THAT
ALLOW NOT REQUIRE THE CITY OF
MERCED TO ANNEX THE CAMPUS
THROUGH A ROAD STRIP
ANNEXATION. WHILE CONTINUING TO
REQUIRE ANY PROPOSED ANNEXATION
TO RECEIVE LASKO APPROVAL. ONCE
THE CAMPUS IS ANNEXED THE BILL
WILL SUBSEQUENTLY ALLOW
CONTIGUOUS PROPERTIES TO BE
ANNEXED WHILE CONTINUING TO
REQUIRE LAUGHTER APPROVAL.
OUTSIDE THE BENEFITS OF THE
CAMPUS THIS ARRANGEMENT WILL
ALSO DIRECTLY BENEFIT THE MANY
UNDERSERVED AND LOW INCOME HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE MERCED. THE
VIRGINIA SMITH TRUST DONATED
THE LAND UC MERCED CURRENTLY
OCCUPIES AND OWNS ADDITIONAL
LAND CONTIGUOUS TO THE SOUTHERN
BOUNDARY OF THE CAMPUS. THE
TRUST IS OPERATED BY THE MERCED
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
IT'S PROCEEDS ARE DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR STUDENTS GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL WITHIN THE CITY OF
BURSA. ANY DEVELOP THE BENEFITS
THE TRUST ENHANCES THE
SCHOLARSHIP FUND. LOCAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CITY
COUNTY YOU SEE AN MERCED
LAUGHTER ON GOING AND I WANT TO
THANK CAL LAUGHED GO FOR THE
REMAINING NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
IN RECOGNITION OF THOSE LOCAL
CONVERSATIONS. TODAY ON THE
PHONE- IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
HAVE THE MERCED COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS STEVE
KEY CHEN- HE'S- NOT ALWAYS TO
END EXCUSE ME THE PLANNING
EXTRA FOR THE VIRGINIA SMITH
TRUSTS STEVEN PACK. WITH THAT
MADAM CHAIR ALL. ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OR WE CAN MOVE TO THE TESTIMONY
OF THE TWO WITNESSES GREAT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM SUPPORT WITNESSES
STEEP KEYGEN AND A MODERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN THE MIKE PLEASE.
MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM. BOERNER HORVATH AND THEN
A SECOND FROM ROBERT RIVAS.
YES.
IN A WAY HAVING ISSUES CONSERVE
THEN. THE BOTH OF. BOB YEAH
ROOM IT IS. MICHAEL BUT DOCTORS
OKAY. APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
AS WE TRIED OF MANEUVER THE
TECHNICAL PIECE OF THIS.
OKAY.
AS A REMINDER THOSE OF YOU THAT
WILL BE CALLING IN REMEMBER TO
MUTE YOUR PHONES AS YOU CALL IN
AND UNDERNEATH THEM. IT PLEASES
THE CHAIR I COULD. EXPAND MY
TESTIMONY TO- SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE OF THE HISTORY THAT I'M
SURE MR THIESSEN WILL SHARE
WITH YOU. YOU KNOW IF YOU'D
LIKE TO I THINK THAT WOULD BE
NICE WHILE WE WAIT NAY IF WE
JUST CAN'T GET THEM WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND AND THE
SUPPORT BY THE CHAIR SO. WHEN
YOU GO AHEAD OF US THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW- I'VE WORKED
WITH THIS INSTITUTION THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR- SOMETIME- MOST
RECENTLY AS A MEMBER
LEGISLATURE BUT- NEXT MONTH I
WILL CELEBRATE. THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF WHEN I FIRST
TOOK A JOB HERE IS A- RECENTLY-
GRADUATED.STUDENT FROM UC
SANTA BARBARA AND- AT THAT TIME
I WORKED FOR GENTLEMAN THAT
DENNIS CARDOZA WHO WAS OUR
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR
MERCED COUNTY- AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND- WE WERE RIGHT AT
THE KIND OF THE INCEPTION OF UC
MERCED- THEY HAD. APPROVED IT
WE'RE GOING TO THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND- IN PART OF THE
HISTORY OF THAT IS MANY
COMMUNITIES COMPETED TO HAVE A
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND- THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FELT VERY STRONGLY THERE
SHOULD BE ONE- IN OUR IN OUR
AREA. AND FRESH- HAD SOME LAND
SAID HAD SOME AND IT CENTER ONE
OF THE ADVANTAGES LOW. THE
UNIVERSITY NOW FOR SAID IN.
SEVERAL FACT THIS GIFT OF. THE
VIRGINIA SMITH TRUST HAD
OFFERED AND THE VIRGINIA SMITH
TRUST WAS MORE CATTLE RANCH
AND- THEY HAD LEFT THAT. MONEY
THE PROCEEDS OF THE RANCH TO
BENEFIT THE LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND SCHOLARSHIPS IN
FACT I RECEIVED A SCHOLARSHIP
AS A YOUNG PERSON FROM THE
VIRGINIA SMITH- FUND. AN
OBVIOUSLY BY DONATING SOME LAND
TO BUILD THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THEY- OFFERED A GREAT
DEAL TO THE STATE BUT THEY ALSO
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY OF
POTENTIAL DEVELOPMENT THE
FUTURE ON SOME OF THAT LAND
WHICH WOULD THEN GENERATE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TOWARD
SCHOLARSHIP FUNDS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THE BILL THAT I HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY MEMBERS IS KIND OF THE-
TWENTY YEARS LATER FRUITION OF
THAT VISION RIGHT- WE HAVE
STRUGGLED TO DEVELOP THAT LAND
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE-
PROVISIONS REQUIRING CITIES TO
GROW- OUTWARD. AND BECAUSE-THIS- UNIVERSITY THIS STATE
INVESTMENT HAD BEEN PLACED-
SOME MILES OUTSIDE THE CITY
BOUNDARIES SO- TODAY WERE ABLE
TO BRING A BILL FORWARD THAT
WOULD- I THINK FAST TRACK SOME
OF THAT DEVELOPMENT WOULD FAST
TRACK FUNDS INTO THOSE- YOU
KNOW INTO THESE- TRUST THAT
WOULD BENEFIT YOUNG PEOPLE- NOT
TO MENTION. WOULD BENEFIT THE
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS- AT THAT
UNIVERSITY WHO- ARE EAGER TO
HAVE A COFFEE SHOP ACROSS THE
STREET FOR. SOME STUDENT
HOUSING ACROSS THE STREET SOME
OF THOSE OPTIONS AND THEN GOING
FORWARD WILL BE ABLE TO KIND
OF- MARY THE CITY OF MERCED
WITH THE STATE- UNIVERSE OF
CALIFORNIA AS THEY GROW TOWARDS
EACH OTHER. SO THIS IS REALLY A
WIN WIN WIN I REALIZE IT'S A
RARE EXCEPTION THERE WERE BUT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ASKING YOU
KNOW FOR EACH FOR THAT BUT I
THINK. THE MORE YOU LOOK INTO
IT AND- HISTORY OF THIS- IN
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY- FOR ALL
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION- TODAY A. I WOULD
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. I'M I
JUST WANNA SAY THE WHAT YOU SEE
MERCED IS DONE IS PHENOMENAL
AND I AM SO IMPRESSED BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING UP THE CAMPUS
IN OFFERING OPPORTUNITIES OUT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY- WE HAVE
HAD EVEN- MY CHIEF OF STAFF
DAUGHTERS GRADUATED FROM THERE
AND LOVES THE PLACE AND STILL
GOING TO SCHOOL THERE. BUT
ANYWAY- WITH THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE A PAUSE BECAUSE WE'RE
HAVING TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO
YOUR- I THINK IF IT'S OKAY WITH
THE RIVER WHEN I. YEAH WHAT GO
HEAD TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS ON.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT. GO AHEAD
ASK ME SOME REMEMBER THANK YOU
INTO THE CHAIRMAN GRADE JUST A
QUICK QUESTION ON THE SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE ON THERE IT IS THE
CITY OF OR SAID THAT HAS A SPUR
OF INFLUENC IN THAT AREA THAT.
LOOKS TO BE ANNEXED YES. SO IT
WOULD BE AN APPLICATION FROM
THE CITY OF MERCED TO THE LOCAL
LAUGH CO TO START THE
ANNEXATION PROCESS. THAT'S
THANK YOU SO LOCAL. IS STILL
INTACT THIS BILL DOES NOT BEING
TO STREAMLINE THAT. RIGHT THAT
THE LOCAL PROCESS TO LAUGH
BECAUSE INTACT FOR THE
ANNEXATION PROCESS. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S YOU KNOW
WE'VE WORKED HAND IN GLOVE
WITH- THAT LOCAL LASKO- AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CAL LAUGHED
GO TO- COME UP WITH A- A PATH
FORWARD THAT THAT KEEPS INTACT
THE SPIRIT OF- BUT THE SPIRIT
OF THAT- LEGAL REQUIREMENT
RIGHT THAT. THAT YOU COULD LOOK
AT AS A LOCAL CRIME AND OF
COURSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT THAT'S A STATE
REQUIREMENT THAT WE IMPOSED ON
THE LOCALS MANY YEARS AGO THAT
WERE ACTUALLY. A LITTLE RESPITE
FROM IN ORDER TO ALLOW THESE TO
COMMUNITIES TO GROW TOGETHER
BUT THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
THANK YOU. OKAY OKAY. OKAY THE
QUESTION YES GOOD ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY YEAH AND
I JUST HAVE A SIMPLE QUICK
QUESTION ABOUT HOW FAR IS THE
CAMPUS FROM MERCED. I ROUGHLY.
THE COUPLE MILES THE TWO TO
FOUR MILES DEPENDING ON. A PART
OF MERCED YOUR SHIPMENT THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION- IF FOR. MOTION AND A
SECOND- I WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE
THAT WE VOTE ON THIS NOW IF
THERE'S ANY DIFFICULTY WE CAN
COME BACK TO THIS LATER BUT
BASED UPON OUR TECHNICAL.
ISSUES I'D LIKE TO MOVE THIS
ALONG A BECAUSE THIS ONE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS A COMMITTEE
THIS BEING WAITING ON HIM AS
WELL SO THAT BEING SAID I HAVE
A MOTION BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BORDER HARD WORK AND I'VE GOT A
ROOM- SECOND BY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. I DON'T THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT OKAY OKAY. SO
A MOTION AND A SECOND US
SECRETARY. SECRETARY GO HADN'T
AND SHE'S GOING TO BEG. THE.
OKAY. I'M ENOUGH THE MODERATOR
TO PATCH THROUGH ONE OF THE
CALLERS PLEASE. THE MODERATOR
THEIR. ALL BAKER IS YOUR LINE
ARE AND MUTED PLEASE ANYA
CHIRLA LINE TO SPEAK. GOOD
MORNING. TO STEVE KEY CHEN ARE
YOU ON THE PHONE OR STIFF PACK
YES I AM I WASN'T SURE THAT YOU
WERE CALLING FOR ME UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THIS MY TIME
TO TESTIFY YES PLEASE. AND A
NOW OKAY SO. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
STEVE KITCHEN I'M MERCED COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AS
WELL AS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE REGION'S MOST TRUSTED I
WANT TO MAKE THREE QUICK POINTS
REGARDING A. B. THIRTY THREE
TWELVE- FIRST OF ALL THE V. S.
P. THE VIRGINIA SCRIPT TRUST-
WAS CREATED. IT BUT THERE
AROUND NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
TO- SUPPORT THE CHILDREN OF
MERCED AND PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR CHILDREN. HEADING TO FOUR
UNIVERSITIES- IN THE MID
NINETIES THE TRUSTED BUT-
CREATED EXCHANGE WITH IT- THE
UC REGENTS TO PROVIDE FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES OF LAND FOR THE
TENTH CAMPUS WHICH BECAME UC
MERCED AS WE ALL KNOW. AND AS
PART OF THAT YEAH I EXCHANGE
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT THAT
PROBABLY WOULD COME BACK TO THE
V. S. T. TO DEVELOP A COMMUNITY
THAT WOULD GROW RIGHTALONGSIDE
OF YOU SEE MERCED. IMMEDIACY
WOULD BENEFIT WITH THIS
RELATIONSHIP BY BUILDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR A LARGER
MUCH LARGER SCHOLARSHIP BUT IN
DOWN WITH THAT WOULD FUND
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR CHILDREN
ACROSS THE COUNTY OF MERCED IT
WAS CALLED THE MERCED PROMISE
OF THE TIME. AND TWENTY FIVE
YEARS HAVE PASSED AND DURING
THIS PERIOD AND- WE ARE ON THE
VERGE OF MOVING OUR PROJECT
FORWARD BUT OF COURSE WE NEED
THE ASSISTANCE- BABY THIRTY
TWELVE. TO HAVE- AN ANNEXATION
OCCUR OF THE UNIVERSITY SO THAT
AS A- NEIGHBORING PROPERTY
SHRUBBERY WE CAN OBTAIN CITY
SERVICES THE S. T. IS NOT LIKE
ANY OTHER DEVELOPER BECAUSE THE
MONEY GENERATED FROM THIS
PROJECT WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
CITIZENS CHILDREN OF MERCED ON.
SCHOLARSHIPS WILL DELIVER
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR ONCE
DEVELOPMENT IS PLEADED. WE'VE
ALREADY MISTER GENERATION A
LOCAL STUDENTS LET'S NOT MISS
ANOTHER ONE ON OUR WATCH- I'D
BE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER T. IS MISTER
PECK AVAILABLE. MODERATE YES
AFTERNOON. AFTERNOON GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS STEVEN ACKERMAN THE
PRIMARY BUT SPEAKING IN FAVOR
OF EIGHTY THIRTY THREE TWELVE.
AS A PROFESSIONAL EXTRA BY
PLANET ASKED FORTY FIVE YEARS.
I'VE WORKED ON HOUSING AND
COMMERCIAL FELLOW PROJECTS AND
RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES. IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AMOUNTS OF
COVERAGE. MOST OF IT THE INSIDE
THE LASKO GENERAL PLANT LAW AND
ZONING BOX. DOES REGULATION
SHOES PROVIDEGUIDANCE ON HOW
TO DO THE RIGHT THING THE RIGHT
WAY. HOWEVER UC UNIVERSITY
PROJECT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT BOX.
THE CITY COUNTY LAUGHTER WHEN
YOU SEE AGREED THAT YOU SEE AT
THE UNIVERSITY PROPERTIES. YES
DAY SHOULD BE ANNEXED THE CITY
AND THAT THE CITY OF. THE TO
PROVIDE URBAN SERVICES. TO THAT
END THE CITY COUNTY AND
RECESSED LASKO SPORT ALL THE
TRADITIONAL MEANS. OF ANNEXING
YOU SPEAK. PROPERTIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO THEM
UNDER THE COURT CASE IN KNOCKED
HERTZBERG ACT. THESE HAVE
INCLUDED IT SHOULD YOU WOULD
SEND A TRADITION AND A QUARTER
EDUCATION. A RECENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE CITY OF
RESPECT. HE WAS SENATE STATION
APPROACH IS NOT FEASIBLE IN THE
NEAR TERM AND MAY NEVER BE
FEASIBLE. A QUARTER AN
OCCASIONAL ON BELL ROAD HAS
ALSO BEEN EXPORT BUT THERE'S
BEEN NO INDICATION OF ANY
PROPERTIES. NOT THE BALLOT FOR
AN X. ANY TYPE SO. LEFT WITH
ONLY THESE TWO EXISTING AND
PEACEFUL ANNOTATION OPTIONS THE
UC AT UNIVERSITY COMMITTEE PLAN.
IT WILL NEVER BE BROUGHT INTO
THE CITY. AND THEY WILL BE
DEVELOPED IN THE COUNTY PER THE
ADOPTED UNIVERSITY WHICH PLAN.
THAT IS NOT A DESIRABLE OUTCOME
NOR ONE THE BILL'S ALLEGE THAT
THE CHANCE OF CORTESE KNOCKS
HERTZBERG ACT. THAT IS WHERE AB
THIRTY THREE TWELVE COME TO. IF
YOU THIRTY THREE TWELVE
PROVIDES CITY COUNTY LAPTOP
THEY'LL TURN A DEAF. BUT A
CHEAP SO MUCH BUT TEN COACHES
DID NOT HERTZBERG BACKED BY
ENSURING THAT THE AGENCY. THAT
IS BEST ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
SERVICE BE APPROVED GROWTH
NAMELY THE CITY WERE SET. IS
THE ONE THAT ACTUALLY DOES SO.
THIRTY FIVE RESULTS. ALLEGE
APPROVED A KEY PRETTY. TWELVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. HEARING NONE
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL UP AT
THE- QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO THE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY.
THING THEN WE HAVE A MOTION-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH ALL THE LOCAL PARTNERS TO
IDENTIFY A REASONABLE SOLUTION
TO WORK THROUGH THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING YOUR DISTRICT
AND YOU SEE MERCED I WILL
SUPPORT BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. AND CONGRATULATIONS WHAT
WE'VE ALL DONE FOR YOU SEE
MERCED AND FOR THE STUDENTS IN
OUR CENTRAL VALLEY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS. RAMOS
I THREE OF US THREE OF US I'D
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL VOEPEL I. HI MISSILE
RIVER GRAY BILLS OUT. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU AND I'LL SEE
YOU SOON NEXT WILL HELP ITEM
NUMBER TWO. THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR SOMETHING BUILT THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA. WELCOME. MAYBE THAT
WILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
I APPRECIATE YOU GIVING A
pTHAT ALL THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
ARE JUGGLING A LOT RIGHT NOW TO
KEEP THIS ALL RIGHT INSIDE-
WANTED TO BE RESPECTABLE
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR THAT-
DIVE RIGHT IN THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED ON PAGE NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS AND TAKE YOUR STAFF
CAN WITH. THE ON XIN I WHICH
I'M ON ONE PRIMARY FACTOR
CONTRIBUTING TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISES
I HAS BEEN THE UNDER PRODUCTION
OF HOUSING UNITS IN THE STATE
LARGE PARCELS OF DEVELOP A LAND
ARE OFTEN UNDER UTILIZED
PARTICULARLY IN THE URBANIZED
INFILL AREAS BECAUSE THE
PROCESS FOR SUBDIVIDING THE LOT
CAN BE TOO CUMBERSOME AND MAKE
A PROJECT IN FEASIBLE. ON
INTENSELY DISCOURAGES THE
CREATION OF HOMES THAT ARE
INTENDED TO BE MORE AFFORDABLE
BY DESIGN AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR CREATING NEW OPTIONAL TOOL
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
ALLOW FOR THE STREAMLINED
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS FOR SMALL
LOT SUBDIVISIONS UNDER
SPECIFIEDCONDITIONS- EXEMPTS
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THE SMALL
LOT MORE NAY THAM SEQUEL AND
UPDATES MANDATORY SUBDIVISION
MAP AT FIND TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
ACTS REQUIREMENTS. ELIGIBLE FOR
THE TYPE OF SMALL LOT
SUBDIVISION A PROPOSED
SUBDIVISION MUST MEET A HOST OF
CONDITIONS INCLUDING- A CERTAIN
ANTI DISPLACEMENT PRODUCTIONS
AND THE PERSON MUST BE LOCATED
AND URBANIZED INFILL YEAH. THIS
BILL CONTINUES THE STATE'S. TO
FACILITATE DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS
OF THE STATE. LEAST LIKELY TO
RESULT IN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
BY REQUIRING THE PARTIAL TO BE
ON AN INFILL SITE. BY PROVIDING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
PROPONENTS THE NEEDED CERTAINTY
WHEN CONSIDERING US TO
SUBDIVIDE A PARCEL THIS BILL
SHOULD HELP SUBURB OF
PRODUCTION OF DESPERATELY
NEEDED HOUSING UNITS. WHILE
MAINTAINING LOCAL CONTROL OF
pBY PHONE TODAY IS ERIC PHILLIPS
OF AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO HIM IF
THAT'S OKAY NOT A CHANCE THANK
YOU MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR OUR SUPPORT
WITH THIS ERIC PHILLIPS.
MODERATOR I WOULD LIKE THE LINE
OPEN FOR ERIC PHILLIPS PLEASE
WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY TWO
SB THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. OKAY
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC PHILLIPS
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU VERY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
AND- AGAIN MY NAME IS ERIC
PHILLIPS I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF POLICY AND LEGISLATION. THAT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION-
AS- MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WE
ARE AN ORGANIZATION WITH OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
PRACTICING PLANNERS BOTH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO BE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THE OFFENSE TO
SPONSOR- THIS BILL AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR- AND WE BELIEVE
THAT IT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPORT. I'M AND UNDERSERVED
BUT DESPERATELY NEEDED SEGMENT
OF THE HOUSING MARKET- THE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING OWNERSHIP
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
MENTIONED DURING HIS REMARKS.
YOUR HAND- TACKLED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS TEND TO FOCUS ON
CREATING MULTI FAMILY RENTAL
HOUSING WHICH IS CLEARLY
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S NOT THE ONLY
FORM OF HOUSING PRODUCTION
WHICH NEED SUPPORT IN
CALIFORNIA AND LEAVE YOU SMALL
LOT SUBDIVISIONS AS A WAY. TO
CREATE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES IN URBAN INTO
AREAS AT HIGHER DENSITIES THAN
TRADITIONAL SINGLE FAMILY
SUBDIVISION WHICH WILL BOTH
INCREASE PRODUCTION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND PROMOTE
CONSTRUCTION EFFICIENCY WHICH
WE BELIEVE WILL. COST YOU A-
BILL AND PURCHASED A HOME
MAKING THESE. HOUSING TAKE
AGAIN MORE X. FOR A LAW.
PERCENTAGE CALIPH. AND ANOTHER.
KEEP OF A THIRTY TUESDAY FOUR
IF A CAR BY THE STEAM FOR HOW
TO RE. AND APPROVE OR DENY.
UNDER THE SAID TO BE MAP. IN A
WAY THAT IS. WITH THE HOUSE
ACCOUNT I RIGHT NOW THE A CON
AND- LAW AND THIS SEEKS TO YOU
RESOLVE BACK AND HARMONIZE BUT
YOU. TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOW
JURISDICTIONS AND ABOUT TO HAVE
CERTAINTY AND I'M- ABOUT HOW
ACROSS THEIR HOUSE. DEVELOPMENT
APPLE I'M SOME OF THE KEY. I AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR FIRST IS
THAT IT HAS OP IN STREAMLINING.
AND BE TEN IS THAT A LOCAL
CHURCH WELL AT DOT. AN ORDER
WHERE THE MARKET AND THE DESIGN
IS APPROACH FOR THIS TYPE. FOR
THAT REASON WE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THAT THE BILL IS
LIMITED TO. SMALL PART IN INTO
AREAS TO MAKE THAT THERE ARE
MANY THE FOR NAKED EMPIRE
EFFECTS WITH THIS. AND THERE'S
GUARD BRAILLE ON THE- TO ENSURE
THAT THERE AND PROD BEING TO.
AT AT LEAST THE DENSITY THAT
WOULD BE PRESUMES TO BE A FOR
AND CAN CHEN AND WHEN THE
HOLDING OUR CROSS OF THIS IS
ANOTHER WAY THAT AB THIRTY TWO
FOUR HARMONIZED WITH BIG DEBTS
CALIFORNIA LAW. AND AS ASSEMBLY
COULD BE MENTIONED DURING HIS
OPEN REMARKS. THE BILL COMES
WITH SB QUAKE SECTION TWO ONE
LOW JURISDICTION INPUT THIS
WORKING. RESTAURANT THE
COMMITTEEMEMBERS MAY HAVE THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
PHILLIPS I'M OTHER AT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF BILL
MOVE THE BELL. WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND ON THE BILL. MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL ON THE LINE PLEASE.
OKAY NO JUST A MOMENT TO MOMENT
ANY PUPIL ALLY TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU OR IF
ANYONE IN FAVOR ONE ZERO AND
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
HEARING NO OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT EITHER WAY ON THE BILL-
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GLORIA YES. WITH MANY OF MY
MENSA SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS BILL I THANK YOU-
GOING FOR HOUSING THAT IS MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN IS REALLY
CREEK CRITICAL FOR OUR HOUSING
MARKET ESPECIALLY UNDER COVE IN
NINETEEN. OR WE KNOW WE NEED TO
HOUSE MORE PEOPLE- AND WEARING
CRISIS- BUT YOUR BILL DOES
ALLOW ONLY IS AN OPT IN BILL
CORRECT CORRECT CORRECT THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- MISTER GLORIA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOS I JUST%
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE COMBAT THE COMMITTEE
AND- EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
WHO HELPED WORK THINK THIS BILL
IS A GOOD PLACE I LOVE THE DOOR
LEASE ON THE MICROPHONES. WE
ASK FOR YOUR IBM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY. I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A COUPLE PEOPLE THAT
COULDN'T GET THROUGH WITH THE
MODERATOR SO IF YOU DON'T MIND
WE'LL GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU
AS WELL IF YOU'RE COMMITTEE
MANCHESTER DEFINITELY HAVE
REALLY JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
BECAUSE RUN AWAY OUT HERE.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE OTHER
CALLS. OKAY THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT SURE WOULD DO ONE MOMENT.
CAN WE DO HAVE A COMMON FROM
THE LINE OF POLLUTION VISUAL TO
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING. ONE
MOMENT HERE. PARDEE ARM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CARE.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER COMMON FROM THE LINE OF
LUIS THE RUN TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
LUPRON DAY I'M LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA BE
HEARD YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. I GET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A MOMENT.
CAN BE JUST A MOMENT. AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE ALL DECISION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU HAVE
PAPER ONE ZERO AS WELL MOMENT.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. AVAILABLE
QUESTION FROM THE LINE FIVE
EIGHT TWO ONE IS OPEN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME. HI MY NAME IS
AT LEAST SEE A VIGIL I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL WITH A STATEMENT
OF SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE TWO
THREE FOUR. THANK YOU. AT THIS
MOMENT THERE ARE NO PERMANENT
NO QUESTION. IS CONTINUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO YOU'VE ALREADY GET
YOUR CLOSING STATEMENT-
SECRETARY. TAKE THE ROLE OF.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY LACKEY I BLOOM BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I RAMOS RAMOS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
AYE VOTE IS A TWO ZERO. BILLS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS SO
REMEMBERED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE DURING THE TRY TO GET
THIS GOING MY PLEASURE CENTER
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR OF LIKE
TO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE CONSENT IN A SECOND.
THIRTY FIRST. CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY HI
LACKEY LACKEY HI BLOOM BLOOM
I'M BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS RAMOS I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WAS A TWO ZERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
BILL WILL BE AN ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
WELCOME MISTER DONNELLY WE WILL
HAVE THE TO SUPPORT WITNESSES-
AFTER YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
A MAN CHAIRMAN PERCY YES PLEASE
THANK YOU A THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY TWO IS A DISTRICT
BILL. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH TO UTILIZE
THE DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTING
METHOD FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
CURB RAMPS. UNDER A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THE CITY IS REQUIRED
TO BUILD FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
CURB RAMPS THAT MEET THE
AMERICAN WITH DISABILITIES ACT
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. FIFTEEN HUNDRED HAVE
ALREADY BEEN BUILT. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE CITY TO ISSUE A
CONTRACT FOR BOTH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION. OF THE
REMAINING CURB RAMPS. THIS WILL
EXPEDITE THE CONTRACTING DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCT STRUCTURE IN
PROCESSES TO ENABLE THE CITY TO
MEET THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DEADLINE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF ALL LONG BEACH
RESIDENTS. THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER THE AUTHORIZATIONS
PROVIDED YOU OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING ORANGE
COUNTY THROUGH A BILL THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. ON THE PHONE
IS AB BROWN AND I BELIEVE TYLER
CURLY REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE MANAGER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A MODERATOR
PLEASE A WITH SUPPORT WITNESSES
AMY BROWN PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING- BE TODAY AND WE
WOULD- ANY BROWN ON BEHALF THE-
CITY OF LONG BEACH WE'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
FOR OFFERING THE BILL. AT THE
STATE IS THIS BILL WILL AID IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TO THE TYPE
TIME- LINE. COMPLY WITH ADA
REQUIREMENTS ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF CODE THAT. WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE LIKE I SAID- TYLER
CURLY BUT LONG BEACH IS HERE.
TO ANSWER ANY PROCESSOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A MISS
BROWN- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
THEY'RE GONNA. SEEING NONE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOME MEMBER-
RAMOS SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO MISS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
SEEING NONE OF WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE AS FOR AYE VOTE. OKAY
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH IS UNDER PRESSURE TO
FIX ITS SIDEWALK SO THAT THEY
ARE ACCEPTABLE FOR EVERYONE AND
THIS BILL ASSIST IN THAT EFFORT
AND I WILL BE ACT VOTING HIGH
FOR YOU TODAY. AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY LACKEY
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I AM
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I RAMOS RAMOS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL AYE
VOEPEL AYE VOTE IS A TWO ZERO.
YEAH ANOTHER THANK YOU BILLS
OUT ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HAVE A GOOD DAY. OF THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO
FOUR TWO ONE. THIS IS A SOME
NEW MEMBER QUIRK SPILL OVER
IT'S GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR STEPPING
IN FOR A MISTER QUIRK I KNOW
THAT HE WOULD LOVE TO BE HERE.
AND I'VE OF HOPING THAT HE WILL
BE HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS F
THERE ANY WITH A REGARDING HIS
BILL. SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO START
PLEASE DO SO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME. TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK- AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE INSURERS. WIRELESS
PROVIDERS CAN DELIVER OUR
RESIDENTS CONTINUED ACCESS. TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
DURING EMERGENCIES. AND
POSSIBLE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT OFFS. SPECIFICALLY
THIS NARROWLY CRAFTED MEASURE.
PUTS A SIXTY DAY DEADLINE. ON
LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPROVE OR
DENY APPLICATIONS. FOR THE
INSTALLATION. OF BACKUP POWER
GENERATORS AT EXISTING MACRO
CELL SITES. AND IT ONLY APPLIES
TO LOW EMISSION FIXED EMERGENCY
GENERATORS THAT ARE UNDER FIFTY
HORSEPOWER AND CERTIFIED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND THIS SUNSET ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. CELL
SITES ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURES THAT ALLOW OR
MOBILE DEVICES TO OPERATE AS WE
RESPOND TO THIS PANDEMIC WE
HAVE ALL EXPERIENCED HOW
CRITICAL IT IS TO STAY
CONNECTED TO OUR MOBILE
DEVICES. AS WE CONTINUE TO DEAL
WITH COVERT NINETEEN WE ARE
ALSO COMING UP ON ANOTHER
WILDFIRE SEASON WITH POSSIBLE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
BY ENERGY COMPANIES WE CANNOT
AFFORD A DISRUPTION IN OUR
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM. LAST YEAR
I DEPENDED ON CELL SERVICES TO
DELIVER BOTH. DELIVER CRITICAL
PIECES OF INFORMATION TO MY
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THE SADDLE
RIDGE FIRE BURNED THROUGH MY
DISTRICT I HATE TO IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
MOBILE DEVICES. TO PREVENT
WILDFIRES ENERGY COMPANIES MAY
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS WHICH
TURNS OFF THE COMMERCIAL POWER
SOURCE TO RESIDENTS IN THE AREA.
IF THE CELL SITES ARE OFF LINE
MOST CELL PHONES WILL BE
INOPERABLE PUTTING PEOPLE AT
RISK DURING A POTENTIAL
EMERGENCY. THIS IS WHY THIS
MEASURE HAS WIDE RANGING
SUPPORT FROM ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS AS
WELL AS MANY OTHER LOCAL
SHERIFFS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS. HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK. SUSAN SANTANA
WITH AT AND T. AND ERIN READ
WITH THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THREE OF US.
OUR MODERATOR PLEASE UP ON THE
LINE PLEASE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO CAROLINA'S ARE A MODERATED
YOU DO NOT NEED TO PRESS THE
KEYS. AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
FIRST COMMENT.
AND NINE FORTY
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
COMMENT. JIM MACEDA-
UNDERSHERIFF CALAVERAS COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. HE THANK
YOU. MODERATOR I AM LOOKING FOR
THREE WITNESSES OF SUSAN
SANTANA ERIN REED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK. ARE THERE BETTER
AND YOUR LINES ARE OPEN THANK
YOU PLEASE SEND ME A CHECK ALL
GOOD NEWS. FIVE BELLCORE MY
GETTING FOR YES YOU ARE MISTER
QUIRK. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US FOR
PREVENTING THE BELL. ON THE
LEFT IN THE PREVIOUS WILDFIRES
THOUGHTLESSNESS LEAD TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR THE GROWING THREAT
OF WILDFIRES POWER OUTAGES AND
OTHER DISASTERS. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE CONSTITUENTS QUICK
ACCESS TO CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY INFORMATION. BECAUSE
FAILURE TO DO SO AND- THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. EIGHT TWENTY OR TWENTY
ONE. MAKE YOUR THREE CAL WE CAN
BE A LONG ONE. RECOGNIZED
MODERATE. MODERATORS SO YOU
HAVE IS YOUR FAULT ON THE CALL
AT THE SAME TIME. YEAH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE NOT SPEAKING THANK
MINIATURE PHONE. WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE WITH I'M A MEMBER
QUIRK PLEASE. THANK YOU. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE CONSTITUENTS
HAVE QUICK ACCESS TO CRITICAL
PUBLIC SAFETY INFORMATION THIS
FAILURE TO DO SO CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE WILL ENABLE MOBILE
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
INSTALL BACKUP POWER GENERATION
AT THE EXISTING. SELF DIED MORE
QUICKLY. AFTER PREPARE IS NOW.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE MEASRE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I BELIEVE
NEXT ON THE LINE WE HAVE SUSAN
SANTANA FROM EIGHTEEN ANTI.
THANK CHAIRMAN AND ASSEMBLY
READ THAT AND QUIRK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS SUSAN SANTANA
AND ON BEHALF OF THE TNC UP
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE. WHICH
WOULD STRENGTHEN PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS BY ENABLING
FASTER DEPLOYMENT OF BACKUP
POWER SOLUTIONS AB MACRO CELL
TOWERS. AS YOU WELL KNOW IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED PS PS
EVENTS THAT WERE UNPRECEDENTED
IN BOTH SCOPE AND SCALE. HE'S
EXTENDED COMMERCIAL POWER
OUTAGES HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS. HE
EVEN ASKED WE NAVIGATE THE
IMPACTS. OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
TODAY. OPENING IN PROVIDERS ARE
PREPARING FOR THE UPCOMING
WILDFIRES EATEN UP TOMORROW AND
THE POSSIBILITY OF WIDESPREAD
PS PS SEVEN IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING OUR PART
TO MAKE SURE OUR NETWORK
REMAINS RESILIENT TO THE LOTS
OF COMMERCIAL POWER. WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING MULTI YEAR CAPITAL
INVESTMENT PROGRAM THAT
INCLUDES NEW FIXED AND MOBILE
GENERATORS BACK UP UPGRADES AND
MUCH MORE. TO THAT END WERE
INVESTING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WHAT THE STAFFERS
HOWEVER INCONSISTENT PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND A LENGTHY
REVIEW TIMES ARE A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER AND SOURCE OF DELAY. SO
WE NEED YOUR HELP PLEASE AND
GENTLEMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE REST OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
RAPIDLY ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF
IMPROVING BACKUP POWER AT CELL
SITES IN TIME FOR UPCOMING
WILDFIRE SEASON. BACKUP POWER
ESPECIALLY DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY AS YOU KNOW IS A
SHARED PRIORITY FOR THE STATE.
NEEDS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
FIRST RESPONDERS AND FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROVIDERS AS WELL AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE IS NARROWLY
TAILORED THAT NARROWLY TAILORED
MEASURE THAT WILL EXPEDITE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE BACKUP
SOLUTION. THIS BILL SPEED UP
THE LOCAL PERMITTING PROCESS
WHILE SAFEGUARD FINAL
PERMITTING OF FORTY WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. PERMITTING FEEDS
AND REIMBURSEMENTS PAID TO
LOCAL AGENCIES WILL NOT BE
AFFECTED BY THIS LEGISLATION
HMP PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES THAT
THE PUBLIC CAN RELY ON. AND
ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEF AND WESTERN FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WHO SUBMITTED THEIR
LETTERS OF SUPPORT YESTERDAY WE
BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATURE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY IN AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE TO ADVANCE OUR
SHARED GOAL OF RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS DURING
WILDFIRES. PST PST VANS AND ANY
OTHER EMERGENCY THAT MAY COME
OUR WAY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WE BASS QUIRK IN THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS AN TELL THEM NOW
ON TO OF MISTER REED. WELL. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR A HARD LIFE AND WE
HAVE A SECOND FROM SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST.
MODERATORS MISTER REED
AVAILABLE. WILL MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I
BELIEVE THERE'S QUITE A FEW ON
THE GENERAL LINE- PLEASE LET
THOSE OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
LINE COME THROUGH. FOR SUPPORT.
YEAH AND WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND TRADITION SO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS IS GERRY PASSED
MORE I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
CONGRESS CALIFORNIA SENIORS-
ALL ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VULNERABLE AND
OFTEN ISOLATED SENIORS WHO RELY
ON THEIR CELL PHONE FOR ACCESS
TO. EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
CRITICAL SAFETY MESSAGES IN
LIFESAVING MEDICAL CARE. WE
NEED A WIRELESS NETWORK TO BE
MORE RESILIENT TO HANDLE
EMERGENCY CUT OFF SOME POWER
OUTAGES. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
BACKUPS IN STREAMLINING OF THE
YACHT PERMITTING PROCESS WE
URGE PASSAGE AND WE ALSO THANK
YOU ALL FOR A MEETING UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES TO
DEAL. WITH THE LAST EMERGENCY
THAT THE STATE PAYS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT NEXT
CALLER. AND OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF. AND
I'M SURE MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON
PER CTA WHERE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE OF WIRELESS
INDUSTRY WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY BUT OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS AND MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE- TO- SELECT
TAKE MORE BACKUP POWER IN A- IN
A- WAY. WE RAN INTO A SMITH ON
TIME THEY HAD INDICATED- SOME
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THOSE WERE
TRYING TO. RESPOND TO BONTA
WILDFIRE OF THAT TO GET THE
BANDS THIS IS A SENSIBLE.
BALANCED WAY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS AND SO WE REQUEST DRIVE
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER LET ME REMIND YOU PLEASE
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR- YOUR RESPONSE. OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
FORTY. IF COMMITTEE TELLING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BROADBAND
CONSORTIUM COVERING SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY WE HAVE HD
MANY OPTIONS OF THE WILD FIRES
EARTHQUAKES WIND INFLUX ACOSTA
INTERRUPTIONS TOP SELF SERVE AT
THE TIME DOING NEEDED NEEDED IT
THE MOST WE URGE OF PASSAGE FOR
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
I NEXT COMIC CON FROM LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MEMBERS JOHNSON CALDERON
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ONE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
CALLER BOTTOM LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RELATED TO THE
CASE THAT THERE CAN. WE ARE IN
OUR- THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER IN SUPPORT. CALLER
SUPPORT LINE TWENTY EIGHT WITH.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DELUDE COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
SENATE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MODERATOR
NEXT PERSON I'VE BEEN SUPPORT.
COMES FROM LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
SUPPORT. WITH. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COURT THE JENSEN
ATTACK THAT ALSO ON BOARD.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANY OTHER
OUT OF OUR LAST ON AND THE POOR
THANK OU VERY MUCH WE ALL KNOW
HOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TRACY RHYME
FROM RC RC AS WELL AS CHARLES
HARVEY FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. TRACY RAIMES.
THERE ARE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS TRACY
RYAN AT THE WELL COUNTY
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN WHILE
COUNTY WE ARE ACTUALLY NOT IN
OPPOSITION- WE'RE A TWEENER
THAT WE MADE A LETTER
CONCERNING ON YOUR BILL. WELL
COUNTY HAVE HISTORICALLY
STRUGGLED WITH A RELIABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES-
GROUNDWORK OF. WITH THE
DIFFICULT HILLY TERRAIN THAT WE
HAVE- PETER IS OF COURSE
THEY'RE ALSO THE ONES AT RISK
FROM WILDFIRES IN ACCORDINGLY
HAVE REPEATEDLY BEEN AFFECTED
ACCESS TO FIRE SERVICE BEING
EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE DURING YES
YET THE BANK- AS A RESIDENCY TO
HAVE ACCESS INFORMATION
REGARDING THE POWER SHUT OFF
AND NEED TO HAVE A WAY TO
CONNECTING KICK UP A LOT HIGHER
OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IN ORDER FOR
OUR TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS CAN MAINTAIN SERVICE
DURING A POWER OUTAGE THEY MUST
HAVE THEIR OWN TOWARDS THE
BACKUP POWER. AND THAT IS WHY
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE AT THE OFFICE STAFF AND
FONG CERTIFIED A PATH FORWARD.
ON THE CELL. OUR CONCERN WITH A
GROUP FOUR ONE IS THAT THE
PERMIT TEAMED UP. PUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE BILL AMEND
CLOSE COULD NINE. COULD BOTH
PROPOSED IN OUR LAB. BUT OUR
THE THAT ONCE THAT IF.
APPLICATION NOT A CLUE AND LET
THE PROJECT NEEDS OF OUR LAW.
THE AUTHOR WATER HAVE BEEN ME.
TO HERE CAN AND WE'RE HOPE THAT
WE REGIONAL BECAUSE THERE'S A
COVER RELATE CRISIS. OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS NOW BEEN A- TO
MOVE. AND BRING THE BILL BEFORE
BORDER DIRECTORS- TO TAKE A
FORMAL POSITION ON HOWEVER WE
HAD SCHEDULED- EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE COULD BE
PRESENTED BEFORE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE NEXT WEEK FOR NORMAL
POSITION. AND WE HOPE THAT WE
COULD PART OF THAT MEETING THAT
OUR CONCERNS. HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED. THANK YOU. THANK
VERY. MUCH MISS RAIMES WE'LL
KNOW CHARLES HARVEY FROM THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN THANK YOU.
OKAY YET CHAU KARBI LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITY- WE
DO ECHO THE CONCURRENCE
NOTIFIED TO GROW COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA- WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WILL BE TAKING THE BY THEM
TO BE REVIEWED BY OUR INTERNAL
POLICY COMMITTEES AND BOARD OF
DIRECTORS- FOR BEFORE TAKING
FORMAL POSITION. I THANK THE
WHILE WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT- TO ENSURE
THAT THAT GOT THE POWER
GENERATION BELL TOWERS YOU KNOW
THE BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE- A
LOT. A WIRELESS DURING UTILITY
INITIATE POWER ROCK. EARNED
AGAIN WITH THE SHOP PROPERTY
AND- GROUP LANGUAGE- MORE
HAPPEN. THAT JUST GAVE. I EVEN
IF THAT PROJECT FELT THE MEET
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS CURRENT LAW-
PERMITTING SHOT CLOCK- THEIR
DIFFICULT BELIEVE WOULD MIND
I'D BE. REGULAR WIRING PITY TO
DIVERT RESOURCES FROM ATTENTION
FROM PENSION SERVICES. AND SO
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE
STATEWIDE ARE FADING I A NEARLY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR REVENUE
SHORTFALL OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS. AND THE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT. OF KOBE
NINETEEN OF FORCES FOR COMPLETE
THE CUT HE THE CRITICAL LOCAL.
PUTTING POLICE FIRE. PUBLIC
WORKS PLANNING AND PERMITTING-
BUT THAT'S WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED. I
WOULD ONLY COMPOUND THE IMPACT
OF. GOING BACK AND CHALLENGES
THE DEBATE OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS BUT- WE ARE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH- WITH. A
SPONSOR AND ON THE TOP. LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE DIALOGUE. WITH
BOTH OF THEM WITH THE HOME WE
CAN REACH YOU AT THE POLLUTION
PART. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE BEEN OTHER.
THAN UP AS- MANY ME TO SHARE.
ERIN REED WAS FINALLY ABLE TO
GET ON FOR SUPPORT I'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO HEAR UP MISTER
REED'S TESTIMONY IF YOU'D LIKE
I APOLOGIZE I HAD SOME
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS GETTING ON-
YEAH AJ EYES FOR THAT THAT'S
FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LEARN READ
REPRESENTING THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA KNOWN AS POOR ACT IT
IS SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
PUBLIC SAFETY MEMBERS. IN NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MEMBER
ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION I PER
OUR SCHOOLS AND THEIR FOURTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS WHO BOTH SHARE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE WHICH WOULD ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TAKE TIME IT'S TIME
TO STEPS TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS. DURING
UPCOMING WILDFIRE SEASONS AND
OTHER POTENTIAL POWER SHUT OFFS
BY ELECTRIC UTILITIES. VERSUS
PONDERS ACROSS THE STATE RELY
ON WIRELESS COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS TO HELP LOCATE
INDIVIDUALS DURING EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS COORDINATE WITH
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ULTIMATELY SAVE MORE LIVES. AT
THE WHITE. WORK IS RESERVE
DURING COMMERCIAL POWER OUTAGES
AS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO
PROVIDING FIRST RESPONDERS WITH
CONNECTIVITY THEY REQUIRED TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND KEEP
COMMUNITIES AND THE PUBLIC SAFE
EVEN ONE COMMERCIAL POWER IS
LOST HE CALIFORNIA'S MUST BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO THE
NINE ONE ONE AND RESERVE
EMERGED IN RECEIVE EMERGENCY
COMMITTEE NOTIFICATIONS IN
COMMUNICATIONS. INCLUDING
WIRELESS IS AMERICA'S DILLARD'S
BROADCAST BY OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE AS A SINGLE AND CRITICAL
GOING TO STREAMLINE THE LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR BACKUP
POWER EQUIPMENT AND SELF SIDES
WHILE SAFEGUARDING FINAL
PERMITTING AUTHORITY WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. THAT STREET
APARTMENT ACOUSTICS GENERATORS
TO MORE CELL SITES WILL HELP
INSURE FIRST RESPONDERS CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PUBLIC AND
EACH OTHER THE LEGISLATURE TO
USE EVERY TOOL AVAILABLE TO YOU
TO RAPIDLY PREPARE FOR THE
GROWING OF WILDFIRES POWER SHUT
US AND OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS
FOR ALL THESE REASONS AND I'VE
TOLD HER YEARS BOTH SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK FOR HIS WORK. ON
IT AND LOSE. AGAIN IN THANK YOU
BETTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MISTER REED ARE THE OF
WE'VE GOT THROUGH OUR SUPPORT.
I BELIEVE IS FINISHED OUR
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION FROM THE PUBLIC.
MODERATOR IF SO. WE DO HAVE ONE
FROM- LINE FIFTY THREE OKAY
LINE IS OPEN IF I HAD GREAT
THANK YOU THANK. THANK YOU IT'S
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE- WE ARE
CLOSE TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR OF THE ANY OTHER
IN OPPOSITION. NO MORE
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT-
SAYING THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL AND I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK MIGHT BE
HELPING ANSWER THIS QUESTION AS
WELL. VERY WELL- I'VE TALKED TO
SOME TECHIES AT. VERIZON AND AT
AND T. I AM BY THE WAY I'M
DOCTOR QUIRK I SUPPORT THIS
BILL VERY STRONG THIS IS A
GREAT DEAL THIS IS AN ATTACK IN
THAT WAY NOW ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT THE TECHIES LIKE THIS AT
LEAST SOME OF THEM AND THIS
ISN'T THE CHAIN OF COMMAND OF
AT AND T. OR VERIZON THESE ARE
JUST THE PEOPLE OUT IN THE
FIELD- RIGHT NOW AT THE MACRO
TOWERS WHICH IS THE MAIN TOWERS
AND THERE'S A LOT A LITTLE
SMALL TOWERS OUT THERE- RIGHT
NOW. THOSE TOWERS WERE BUILT
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME AND
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT-
GEAR IN A DIFFERENT GENERATORS
DIFFERENT BACK UP DIFFERENT
TANGLES THAT BEEN APPROVED
THROUGH THE YEARS THIS WILL
HELP STANDARDIZE TO A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OF QUALITY OVER PROBABLY
ABOUT A THIRD WHAT'S IN THERE
NOW SO THAT'S A GOOD SUPPORT
POINT- AND NOT TO GET TOO FAR
TECHNICAL OR IN THE WEEDS
THAT'S WHERE I LIVE IN MY
WORLD- IF YOU HAVE. A FIFTY
HORSEPOWER GENERATOR WITH A
HUNDRED NINETY GALLON DOUBLE
WALL STORAGE TANK WHICH IS GOOD
FOR FIRE THAT GENERATE SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY SIX WATTS PER
HORSEPOWER THAT'S THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED WHAT'S
THAT WHAT'S THAT DO IT SUCKS UP
FOUR GALLONS OF FUEL AN HOUR SO
IF YOU GO AT FULL POWER THEY
GIVES YOU TWO DAYS OF BACKUP
POWER IF YOU GO AT HALF POWER.
AND I'M ASSUMING THAT THESE NEW
UNITS WOULD BE CONTROLLED
REMOTELY BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
MOST OF WHAT THE TOWERS WORK
NOW ANY WAY YOU CAN GET FOR
DAYS A BACKUP. WITH FOR DAYS A
BACKUP AT HALF POWER THAT'S
PROBABLY ABOUT WHAT THEY WOULD
NEED. YOU HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
GET CREWS IN THEIR- TO REBUILD
REDO. TRANSFER ALL THE RF. SO
THIS IS A VERY GOOD BILL FROM A
TECHNICAL VIEWPOINT. FROM A
REGULATORY VIEWPOINT SPEEDED UP
TO SIXTY DAYS APPROVAL
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE REPLACING
OLD OBSOLETE EQUIPMENT JUST
SIMPLY MAKES SENSE VERY GOOD
DOCTOR QUIRK GREAT BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS TO THE
AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OF WITH THE AUTHOR LIKE TO
CLOSE EITHER YOU BEING. A RIVAS
OR MISTER QUIRK WHATEVER YOU'D
LIKE TO DO. SO AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY BILL POOR. SURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE.
ARE THE ONE DAY THAT I BELIEVE
THAT ALL THE- BOTH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES FROM
MYSELF AT THE STATE. THE STATE
GOALS AND SO I WILL WORK VERY
CLOSELY COOLEY WITH THEM IN
ORDER TO- GET THAT WE ALL FEEL
QUITE WHERE EVERYONE FEELS
COMFORTABLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY- WE HAVE A
MOTION OF HIS BE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS I KNOW YOU AYE. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE IS A
NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL THAT WILL
BETTER PREPARE THE STATE FOR
FUTURE EMERGENCIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SEEING
NONE WE HAVE A MOTION I'D LIKE
TO JUST SAY IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REVIEWS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD ISUPPORT THIS BILLS
GOLFER OF IN DURING RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES IN THE
EVENT OF A POWER OUTAGE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHORS
SUPPORTERS ARE WORKING WITH RC
RC AND THE OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THEY HAVE
BEEN RAISED. WITH THAT IN MIND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY. SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE
PLEASE. MOTION IS DO PASSING RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I AM LACKEY.
LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I RAMOS RAMOS I IT THREE OF US
HI THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT READ US I'D VOEPEL
ELECTRIC. VOEPEL I VOTE IS A
TWO ZERO. I ALSO THINK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- RIVAS AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT YEAH
YOU'RE WELCOME ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE
AND WE HAVE OUR OWN ROBERT
RIVAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
YOU CAN START WHEN YOU'RE READY
SIR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES IT'S- GREAT TO BE
BACK EVEN THOUGH WE ARE HERE
UNDER PRESIDENTE CIRCUMSTANCES-
I DON'T WANT TO THANK OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL AND ON ON THE
ANALYSIS I ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. IS
AMENDMENTS HELP ADDRESS- AND
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
AND CERTAINLY HAVE HELPED TO
MAKE THE BILL A STRONGER. AND
SO CERTAINLY NO ONE WOULD HAVE
PREDICTED HOW QUICKLY THIS
HEALTH CRISIS WHAT TRANSFORM
OUR LIVES. AND ALTHOUGH HERE
IS A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY MOVING
FORWARD. WE CAN BE ABSOLUTELY
CERTAIN THAT ARE PRE PANDEMIC
HOUSING PROBLEMS ARE CERTAINLY
ONLY GONNA GET WORSE THIS THIS
BILL HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE ONE FIVE THREE-
INCENTIVIZE BIKE AND CAR SHARE
PARKING. IN NEW HOUSING-
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS. THIS BILL
IS NOT VERY BROAD IN SCOPE. BUT
CHALLENGES US TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT PARKING
MINIMUMS. IT'S SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY TO HOUSING DID
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS IN
REDUCING THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VEHICLE PARKING SPACES THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE IF THEY
PROVIDE NON REQUIRED LONG TERM
BIKE PARKING SPACES CARSHARING
SPACES OR BOTH. AND I SHOULD
NOTE THAT ALL SUCH VEHICLE
PARKING REDUCTION CREDITS WERE
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED TO BE
CAPPED AT 30% AND SO ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS- THAT THAT THAT WE
TOOK IN IT IT DOESA GREAT JOB
IN IN THE ANALYSIS- IN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE WHEN AND WHY
IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
THIS AMENDMENT. WAS AT THIS 30%
CAP THOSE PROPOSED WAS
AMENDMENT WAS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE VEHICLE PARKING
REDUCTION TEARS AND SO- AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS A TEST
REQUIREMENTS WITH THESE TWO
YEARS SINCE THE ONE SUCH TEAR
WOULD ALLOW A MAX OF UP 230% IF
A PROJECT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
DENSITY BONUS AND IS LOCATED
WITHIN HALF A MILE OF MAJOR
TRANSIT STOP. THE SECOND AND
THERE'S IT- ESSENTIALLY TO
OTHER TEARS BOTH INVOLVING A
MAX OF 50% PARKING REDUCTION IF
THE PROJECT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
IDENTITY BONUS OR IS LOCATED
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF A MAJOR
TRYING TO STOP BUT CERTAINLY
NOTHING IN THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT TO MORE GENERAL
STANDARDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND AS I MENTIONED YOU KNOW
THIS BILL IS NOT VERY BROAD IN
SCOPE- BUT THIS ISSUE OF
PARKING MINIMUMS IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. BECAUSE PARKING
MINIMUMS HAVE UNINTENDED
IMPACTS. PARKING MINIMUMS DRIVE
UP THE COST OF HOUSING. THEY
CAN REDUCE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
PRODUCED. AND IN SOME INSTANCES
HAVING THIS FLEXIBILITY AS THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO STRATEGICALLY
REDUCE VEHICLE PARKING SPACES
WILL PROMOTE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MOBILITY IT COULD BOOST PUBLIC
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP WHERE
ASSESSABLE IN AVAILABLE IT
COULD ENCOURAGE MORE CYCLING
AND PUT TO USE CALIFORNIA'S
EXPANDING NETWORK OF BIKE LANES
AND GREEN WAYS. SUCH A THIS
BILL- THREE ONE FIVE THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ONE FIVE
THREE COULD SERIOUSLY INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF BIKE IN CARSHARE
PARKING IN HOUSING. DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS WHILE ALSO MITIGATING
OR ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE
UNINTENDED IMPACT OF PARKING
MINIMUMS. AND I'M JOINED HERE
TODAY BY TWO IN THIS IS THE
FIRST BEING DAY SNYDER THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAL BIKE
WHOSE. WHO THEY BECAME A BILL
SPONSOR. AND ZACH HILTON A
DISTRICT A CONSTITUENT AND A
MEMBER OF THE GILROY OF- THE
CITY OF GILROY BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN COMMITTEE NOW I'M
GOING TO HEAD OVER TO ZAC BUT
BEFORE I DO I SHOULD MENTION.
THAT THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL
CAME FROM ZACK IT WAS AN IDEA
THAT WAS GENERATED FROM OUR
FIRST EVER THERE OUGHT TO BE A
LAW PROGRAM. AND AS I MENTIONED
BECAUSE AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF- OF
THE CITY OF GILROY. AS I
MENTIONED HE'S PART OF. A
MEMBER WAS RECENTLY CHAIR OF
THE BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN
COMMITTING GILROY. AND HE
PROPOSED THIS IDEA BCAUSE HE
WANTED TO FIND A WAY. TO
INCREASE BY PARKING IN THE CITY
OF GILROY. AND SO CERTAINLY WE
ARE HERE THIS BILL THREE ONE
FIVE THREE THIS IS IT IT IS AN
INNOVATIVE A CREATIVE IDEA
AROUND PARKING MINIMUMS. KNOWS
ALL MADE POSSIBLE BY BY ZACH.
AND YOU KNOW HIS ADVOCACY THEN
THE CITY OF GALWAY SO WITH THAT
I WILL HAND IT OVER TO THEM.
MODERATOR. OPEN THE LINE FOR
SUPPORT FROM ZAKKA HILTON
PLEASE. YEAH AND IT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL AND THE
SECOND. IS THAT KILLED IN THERE
PLEASE. SELECT COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF AND THE PUBLIC
I'M JACKI HOLDEN RESIDENT OF
GILROY CALIFORNIA IN CHAIR OF
THE GIVE YOU GO RIGHT BY SCHOOL
PENSION COMMITTEE FOR ME THEY
NEED FOR A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTY
THREE AGAIN IN AUGUST TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN I FOUND OUT
DURING A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
REVIEW. THAT BIKE PARKING IN
MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
INVOLUNTARY. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUILDING CODE
THE RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPER
STATED A GALLERY NEEDED TO
REFERENCE A CODE THAT STATED BY
PARKING WAS REQUIRED. AND THAT
IS AT THE SAME TIME THE
DEVELOPERS LOOKING FOR CREATIVE
WAYS TO REDUCE THEIR VEHICLE
PARKING MINIMUMS. THERE WAS NO
SUCH LOCAL ORDINANCE OR CLOTHES
OR CODE IN YOUR- IMAGINE HAVING
A FAMILY OF FOUR STILL LIVE IN
AN APARTMENT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD ON. YOU YOUR SPOUSE AND
KIDS WANT TO RIDE BIKES WELL
WHERE DO YOU STORE THEM. THAT
RIGHT THERE MAKES PEOPLE RELY
ON CARS FOR MORE COMPLETE LOOK
MORE TRAFFIC AND CONGESTION IN
THE COMMUNITY. RATHER THAN
SUPPORTING THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
YOU WILL GET IN THE CAR AND
DRIVE SOMEWHERE ELSE. IF THAT'S
MORE CONVENIENT. IN TODAY'S
HOUSING MARKET ONE IN THREE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. IN
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T OWN A CAR.
NOT ALL FAMILIES WILL BUILD ON
OUR OWN AND SOME WILL STAY IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND DEFINITELY.
WHETHER A BIKE YOU USED FOR
RECREATION OR ESSENTIAL
TRANSPORTATION PRESIDENT NEED
US. AT FACE SECURE PLACE TO
STORE THEIR BICYCLES. I AM HERE
IN SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE AND THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AS IT WILL HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT IN CALIFORNIA BY
ACHIEVING OUR GOAL TO REDUCE.
EMISSIONS FROM ON ROAD. ON ROAD
MOTOR VEHICLES IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY BANKER YOU KNOW
RESIDENT COMMUTERS AND
VISITORS. TO KNOW JEFF FROM
VEHICLES TO BIKING. AND
INCREASES BY KEEN AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVE FOR SHORT.
AND FIRST LAST MILE TRIPS.
CONTINUES OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
ENCOURAGE RESIDENTS USES
BENDABLE THAT THE CHANCE THAT.
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO REDUCE
OUR NECK ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
THEIR INNOVATIVE TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS. THIS BILL PROVIDES A
SECURE PLACE FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES TO STORE THEIR
pACTIVE IN THE CHANGE HAS BEEN
ABLE TRANSIT LIKE BIKE IN CAR
SURE USAGE. AT THE STATE WE ARE
ACTIVELY BREAKING ADVANCING
IDEAS AND PROJECTS THE PROMOTE
THE CONCEPT OF FREE RANGE
PEOPLE. WE ADVOCATE FOR
BUILDING AND PLANNING THAT
CONSIDERS FUTURE GENERATIONS AS
WELL AS CURRENT RESIDENT WHO
DON'T ON CARS. IT DANTE
MOBILITY OPTION OPTIONS
REFLECTS WHAT WE ARE TEACHING
THE YOUTH IN OUR COMMUNITY SAFE
ROUTES TO SCHOOL. ALL MULTI
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
BY PARKING IT CALIFORNIA'S
VOLUNTARY AND LET THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION HAS BEEN ORDER.
FAMILY YOUNG ADULTS AND SENIORS
ALL NEED IT THEY PLACE MR THEIR
BIKE AND INCENTIVES NOT DRIVE
THEIR CARS. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
THE VISION OF THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. AND ENHANCES
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
LIVABILITY LONG TERM BIKE
PARKING WOULD COMBINE THE CARS
HERE. A KEY ROLE IN PROVIDING
THE STATE'S SUSTAINABLE.
INTEGRATED AND EFFICIENT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THANK YOU
AND A CONCLUSION I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BUT-
THANK YOU. MUCH IS THAT HELL TO
IS THE SNYDER. TO BE PER. I AM
HERE HI. MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU MY
NAME IS DAVE SNYDER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION.
WE ARE- A STATEWIDE GROUP THAT
WORKS TO HELP MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER WORK
COMMUNITY FOCUSED ORGANIZATION
THAT WANTS TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE EQUITABLE MORE
HEALTHY MORE PROSPEROUS MORE
INCLUSIVE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
PERHAPS MORE JOYFUL BECAUSE
PEOPLE CAN RELY ON BICYCLIN TO
GET AROUND. WE WORK WITH DOZENS
OF COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND THE STATE WHO THEMSELVES
REPRESENT ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT
TO SEE MORE BICYCLING. AND WE
WORK AT THE STATE LEVEL WITH
STATE AGENCIES- AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE POLICIES
THAT HELP THEM BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL%
THIS AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE
IS ONE OF THOSE POLICIES. IT'S
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO US IN THE
MEMORY OF US FOR- INTRODUCING
IT AND TO THAT COMMITTEE FOR
THE AMENDMENTS WHICH TO MAKE
THIS A BETTER BILL. NOW IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME TO ADVANCE THIS.
IT WILL MAKE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE WE HAVE A BIG
HOUSING CRISIS IN THIS WILL DO
A LOT TO HELP MAKE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE I'LL DESCRIBE A
SCENARIO WHERE ITMAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IF YOU'RE BUILDING-
MEDIUM SIZED MULTI UNIT
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING AND THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ARE SUCH
THAT. BY THE STATE SAY THERE'S
TWENTY FIVE UNITS YOU CAN STEP
TOWARD TWENTY FIVE SPACES
REQUIRED IF YOU CAN FIT TWENTY
ON THE GROUND FLOOR BUT HAVING
TO FIT TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES YOU
TO DIG A HOLE TO BUILD AN
UNDERGROUND GARAGE. THAT DRIVES
OFF YOUR COST SO MUCH THAT YOU
CAN'T AFFORD TO PROVIDE ANY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BY MAKING
IT EASIER FOR DEVELOPERS TO NOT
HAVE TO BUILD- HUGE UNDERGROUND
GARAGE. WE CAN MAKE HOUSING
MORE AFFORDABLE TO SAME TIME
MAKING BICYCLE PARKING IN
BICYCLING MORE FEASIBLE. AND
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SECURE BY PARKING
AND A LOT OF COMMUNITIES YOU
CAN'T LEAVE YOUR BIKE ON THE
STREET OVERNIGHT. AND I'M I
CAN'T QUITE SAM A YOUNG GUY
ANYMORE BUT- I'M USED TO
CARRYING MY BIKE UPSTAIRS IN MY
ON MY RIGHT SIDE OF MY BODY IS
STRONGER BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN'T DO THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
RELY ON THEIR BIKES AND THEY
CAN'T CARRY. BIKES UP STAIRS
MAYBE THEY HAVE A HEAVY BIKE
THAT THE USED THEIR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL. PEOPLE NEED A SECURE
INDOOR PLACE TO PARK THEIR
BIKES AND STILL PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT CENTER. SET UP TO DO
THAT. LIKE I SAID WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR CNN I'M- ANY QUESTIONS THAT
ANYONE MIGHT HAVE. ABOUT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER SNYDER.
MODERATOR ARE THERE IN OTHER
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE BRING THEM ON WE DO HAVE
SURE ABSOLUTELY WE DO HAVE A
FEW THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE AND
THE FIRST ONE COMES FROM LYING
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUR NEXT ONE COMES FROM
THE ON LINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE
LAST ONE IS FROM LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JULIA
RANDOLPH FROM THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND QUIRK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
IT'S A PART. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON HAVE CUED UP AND
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT. THANK
YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. LINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YET
THIS IS LIZ MONTANA LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIAN BE OP
REALLY APPLIED CREATIVE
APPROACH AT THE TOPIC OF THE
STATE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION PROBLEMS I
REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT- TODAY
FOR AT THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE MAKE YOU
RIGHT NOW PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. HEARING NONE MODERATOR WE
CHECK IN ON THE LINE IF THERE
ARE ANY THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO HAVE SOMEONE THAT JUST
CUED UP LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR.
MADE ADAM RIGHT WE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE ACTUALLY
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT DIDN'T UP
EARLIER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SOUNDS LIKE WE DON'T
DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ONLY SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BORDER HARPER YES I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR BEING CREATIVE
ABOUT HOW DO WE INCREASE BY
PARKING I AGREE WHEN YOU HAVE
AN E. BIKE TO TAKE YOUR KIDS TO
SCHOOL IT IS VERY DIFFICULT UP
BY IT TAKE THAT UP STAIRS AND
YOU DO NEED TO HAVE PARKING IN
STORAGE FOR THAT. MY CONCERN
AND PERHAPS THE AUTHOR CAN
ADDRESS THIS IS- WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT. YOUR MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE MAMMOTH SO THIS BILL IS
THAT 15% REDUCTION IS GIVEN FOR
ANY DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS AND
IS NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT-
CONNECTIVITY TO TRANSIT- THE
AVAILABILITY OF BIKE LANES.
AVAILABILITY IS SAFE ROUTES TO
SCHOOL SO I CAN I AGREE THAT IN
AREAS WHERE. IT THERE ARE THOSE
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS IT WOULD BE
OPPORTUNE FOR THE CITY TO PASS
LOCAL ORDINANCES. THAT WOULD
INCENTIVIZE IT. COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME SO I HAVE A
BUT LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY ON
THAT. YEAH I CAN TRY TO ADDRESS
IT I THINK YOU KNOW ORIGINALLY
AS A BILL I PROPOSE JUST A
BLANKET CAP OF 30% AND WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS YOU HAD THIS
TIERED STRUCTURE. TO TAKE I
THINK YOUR CONCERN INTO ACCOUNT
THE FACT THAT- THOSE THOSE
TEARS REFLECT A REDUCTION IN IN
IN THE NOVEL CAPS BASED ON
LOCATION. SO IF YOU HAVE I'M A
DENSITY BONUS YOU'RE ALLOWED A
FIFTY PERCENT. OF UP TO A 50%
REDUCTION- AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT DOES H
BONUS IT ALSO TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE LOCATION YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE NOT IF. THE PROJECT
IS PROPOSED TO BE LOCATED IN
HALF MILE OF TRANSIT THEN YOU
KNOW YOU'RE ALLOWED- A MAX OF
THE FIFTY PERCENT- MAYBE THE
SPONSORS BEGIN TO YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
I'M- WILLING TO. WORK WITH YOU
YOURSELF AND- A YOU KNOW OUR
SPONSORS A CALL BY. FOR TO
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERN TO YOU
KNOW BE SURE THAT WOULD
BUILDING AND MORE- ASSURANCES
THAT WE ARE STRATEGICALLY-
USING THIS BILL TO BUILD- MORE
BIKESHARE OPPORTUNITIES I'M I'M
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS THAT SO.
THANK YOU AND I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF THE SPONSORS WANT TO
ADDRESS IT I SPECIFIC CONCERNS
ABOUT DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS
THAT WE GET A REDUCTION FOR
BIKING WHERE THERE'S NO ACCESS.
AND NO PLANS FOR- ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION BIKE LANES SAFE
ROUTES TO SCHOOL SO. WE HAVE A
PROJECT THAT THE DENSITY BUT AS
PROJECT IN A RURAL AREA OF MY
CITY AND THERE'S NO SAFE ROUTES
TO SCHOOL THERE'S NO BY PLANES
THERE'S NO PLAN FOR BIKE LANES
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WORLD WITH
FOR BIKE LANES. AND I DON'T
WANT TO SEE THAT PARTICULAR
PROJECT AT A DENSITY BONUS
RETIRED BIRD I REDUCTION
PARKING WHAT IS ALREADY REDUCED
FROM THE CITY'S PARKING
STANDARDS SERVE I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S A SPECIFIC THING WE
DON'T WANT TO DRESS IT NOW I'M
HAPPY. VOTE ON THE DAY BILL
TODAY. THEN I CAN. THE AUTHOR
IF THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE JUST A PAGE FOR
A LOT OF HIGHLY AREAS WERE.
MOST YOUR AVERAGE YOU KNOW
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY CROWD NEEDS TO
HAVE E. BIKES IN ORDER TO
MANAGE THOSE HOUSE IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO PUT IN SOMETHING OR
SELECT VEHICLE STRIPPING. FOR
OUR LA. HE BY. FOR THEIR SPOTS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE
A DIFFERENCE. HOW FEASIBLE THAT
APPLE WOULD BE. AND YOU KNOW IF
I CAN MAKE- ONE MORE COMMENT I
THINK WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITY ASPECT OF THIS
IN THE SENSE THAT WE HAVE. A
NETWORK OF BIKE LANES THAT IS
EXPANDING AT A RAPID PACE- IN
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE REALLY
YOU KNOW THERE WAS A- I BELIEVE
A STUDY- THAT WAS COMMISSIONED
BY CALTRANS IS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO THAT TALKED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE MOBILITY AND REALLY
WORKING TO. EXPAND INTO VERSIFI
THE WAY WE MOVE FROM POINT A TO
POINT B. BY UTILIZING BIKE
LANES AND SO CERTAINLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- COULD REALLY.
COMPLEMENT YOU KNOW WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN DOT. ORG WILL BE
DONE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL.
YES I'M ARE GOING TO BE A- NOT
VOTE ON THIS BECAUSE I CAN SEE
WHERE IT FITS CERTAIN DISTRICTS
QUITE WELL AND YOU KNOW GOOD
BILL FOR THEM NOT A GOOD BILL
FOR MY DISTRICT MY DISTRICT IS-
A LARGE RURAL GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
AND WITH VERY FEW BIKE LANES
AND THERE'S CERTAIN PERIODS OF
TIME WHERE IF YOU'RE RIDING A
BICYCLE IN OUR BACK ROADYOU
HAVE A DEATH WISH I MEAN IT'S A
SIMPLE AS THAT NOW IT MIGHT
URBAN AREAS. THERE ARE. WORKING
POOR MIDDLE CLASS AND NEAR THE
TRANSIT AREAS YOU THERE'S NO
DENSITY REALLY SO ONCE AGAIN- I
HAVE CERTAIN CITIES THAT
RECENTLY ART IN THE BIKE LANE
SO I HAVE ONE CITY THAT THIS
BILL IS PERFECT FOR SO. I'M
GOOD AND NOT VOTE JUST OUT OF
RESPECT AND- REPRESENTING MY
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. US SING NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION I BELIEVE AND
THE SECOND. AND I WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS YEAH SO THE ONE I
THINK- SPONSOR WANT TO THINK OF
CONSIDER OF MY DISTRICT THAT
KILLED IN FOR BEING ON THE LINE
AND REQUEST WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I. BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER. ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS-
pI'LL HELP THIS THE STATE
ACHIEVE ITS ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
BY ENCOURAGING ACT OF AN
ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF
TRANSPORTATION WHILE ALSO
REDUCING THE COST OF. HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE LANGUAGE. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
SCRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I AT LACKEY.
LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NOT VOTING
RAMOS RAMOS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI ROBERT READ US
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL NOT
VOTING VOTING VOEPEL NOT
VOTING- VOTE IS. SIX TWO ZERO
BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS NEXT OUR
NEXT BILL TODAY IT WAS- A BIG
ENOUGH ITEM TEN AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE WHERE DOES IT WILL BE
PRESENTED TODAY BY
ROBERT RIVAS. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO START THANK YOU MYSTERY WAS
AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUFFY WICKS. ON
BEHALF OF MISS WICKS I'D LIKE
TO THINK- COMMITTEE STAFF THE
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED ALL THE OF
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. THERE
IS- NO QUESTION THAT OUR
CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS HAS
CREATED NEW CHALLENGES FOR OUR
STATE. UP FOR CONSTITUENCIES
BACK HOME AND CERTAINLY- WILL
ONLY EXACERBATE OUR CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS. SO NOW PRIOR TO
THIS PANDEMIC NO THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE YEAR THAT
ARE LEGISLATURE'S GONNA FOCUS
ON REVERSING THE DECADES OF
UNDER BUILDING. OUR FOCUS WAS
GOING TO ALL BE ABOUT HOUSING
PRODUCTION THIS YEAR. ABOUT
CREATING HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR A GROWING NUMBER OF
VULNERABLE AND HOUSING AND
SECURE CALIFORNIANS. AND AS WE
ALL KNOW SOLVING OUR HOUSING
PROBLEMS HAS NOT BEEN EASY AND
WILL NOT BE EASY MOVING FORWARD.
MANY ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS.
THIS ISSUE. AND TEMAS ISIS
POINT HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
MANY OTHER STATES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY YOU HAVE RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
HELPING ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
SHORTAGE. AND SO AS LARGE PROP
HOLDERS THEY ARE THEY ARE IN A
GOOD POSITION TO FILL AN
IMPORTANT GAP. ESPECIALLY AT A
TIME WHEN A LAND FOR HOUSING
COMES AT A PREMIUM. AS WE ALL
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA ELSEWHERE
ABSENT A HOUSING SUBSIDY THE
HIGH COST OF LAND. MAKES
HOUSING INCREDIBLY ON
AFFORDABLE. UNFORTUNATELY PLANS
TO BUILD NEW HOUSING ON
RELIGIOUS PROPERTY OPTED BASS
ROAD BLOCKS ONE SUCH ROADBLOCK
IS THE INABILITY TO COUNT
AVAILABLE PROPERTIES FOR
RESIDENTIAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS DUE TO PARKING
MINIMUM REGULATION SET AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THIS BILL SAID THE
BILL EIGHT FIVE ONE ONE EIGHT
FIVE ONE SORRY WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE REDUCTION OF RESIDENTIAL
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ON
RELIGIOUS OR FAITH BASED
PROPERTIES. THIS BILL IS A
NECESSARY STEP TO HELP
STIMULATE HOUSING PRODUCTION
THAT OURSTATE VERY WE DO YOU
KNOW WE- WE DESPERATELY NEED-
YOU KNOW ALL ALL ALL ALL THE
HOUSING PRODUCTION WE CAN GET.
THIS BILL WON'T SOLVE OUR
PROBLEM. BUT THE IMPORTANT
THING IT WILL HELP IT WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOLUTION THAT
THAT THAT WE NEED SO SAID THE
BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE HAS
RECEIVED TREMENDOUS SUPPORT
FROM LOCAL COMMUNITY OF FOR
FROM OUR LOCAL- FAITH GROUPS.
FOR NON PROFITS FROM HOUSING
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND WITH US
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IS OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUFFY
WICKS AND ALSO HERE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS. SIDE
BILLY SIMON A FROM NEW WAY
HOMES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
IT WILL HELP OUR- COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS PLEASE.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU- AND
MANY YOU KNOW ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION HOME SHORT OF WHAT
WE NEED TO BE IN THE STATE I'M
IN THIS LACK OF HOUSING REALLY
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTE TO-
ARE ALMOST AS ISSUES THAT WE
SEE ACROSS. STATE ORDER. AND
THE BOTTOM IS WE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HELP WE HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE ABOUT HOW WE DO IT AS
AS WITH THE NUMBER READ MY ARE
THE LIST ARE REALLY KIND OF SET
UP TO PLATE BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND THEY THEY SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS IMPACT THEIR COMMUNITIES
MANY OF THEM WANT TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- ON ON THE
LAND THAT THEY OWN- BUT THERE
AGAIN CASE WITH- ROADBLOCKS IN
TERMS OF- PROPERTY AND PARKING
REQUIREMENTS- ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON- REASON. WHY THE BILL.
AND THE BAR LINE IN THE BILL
THAT THERE TO HELP TAKE OFF
ROAD BLOCK. SO THAT WE CAN.
SURE THE BILL FOR THE HOUSING
ON THEIR OWN PROPERTY THAT THEY
OWN. THE TURNER CENTER FOR
HEALTH INNOVATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY ONE OF THE AND FROM
HERE. I THINK TANKS ON HOUSING
ISSUES IN THE STATE SOME OF
THEIR APPROXIMATELY. THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
ACRES OF LAND IN CALIFORNIA
USED FOR RELIGIOUS PURPOSES.
THAT COULD BE USED FOR BUILDING
A HOUSING AND CONSTRUCTION. AND
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY ALONE THERE'S
OVER. A THOUSAND ACRES-
AVAILABLE- FOR THIS TYPE OF
HOUSING SO AND AGAIN JUST AS AN
REASON. THAT THIS ISN'T GOING
TO SOLVE ALL THEIR PROBLEMS.
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY ONE CREATIVE
WAY THAT WE CAN. WORK WITH OUR
FAITH COMMUNITY- TO CREATE MORE
SOLUTIONS ON THE ISSUE- I THINK
IT'S A NECESSARY STEP IN
STIMULATING HELPING PRODUCTION
THAT CAL. SO DESPERATELY NEED.
WE'VE HAD- A WIDE- AND DEEP.
LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
WORKING WITH OUR FAITH
COMMUNITIES THE OF ALL TYPES OF
FAITH- ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HORRIBLE HOW
THE ORGANIZATION THAN OTHERS
AND WE HAVE NO. CHILD
OPPOSITION TO DATE ON THE BILL.
FRANKLY ONE OF MY MORE FAVORITE
BILLS THAT WE'VE GOT TO WORK ON
BRINGING TOGETHER ALL THE
DISTRICT. DIFFERENT TYPES OF
VOICES- TOGETHER TO BE A-
SOLUTION. ALLEN AND THE ISSUE
FOR THIRD OF FILLING A GET
WORSE THE COVER NINETEEN RIGHT
THAT TO APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING
NOW OVER THE PHONE TODAY WE A
COMPUTER WITH YOU. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECK. I BELIEVE IS A MISTER.
MODERATOR PLEASE UP AT THE LINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY TIME IN SOME
NEW WAY HOMES HI THAT WILL BE
VERY BRIEF- WE WORK WITH FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- OFTEN
PARTNERING WITH NONPROFIT
DOWNLAND SPECIALLY CHURCHES I A
IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
I'VE SPOKEN WITH AT LEAST A
HUNDRED CHURCHES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN BUILDING.
AFFORDABLE A MIXED INCOME
RENTAL HOUSING BELOW MARKET
RATE COUNTING ON THEIR LAND AND
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE HAVE
PARKING THEY JUST DON'T USE.
OUR HOWEVER THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO USE THAT PARKING AS THE
PARKING FOR THE RESIDENCES THEY
WANT TO CREATE AND IN SOME
CASES THAT SIMPLY STOP THE
HOUSING FROM BEING BUILT SO
WE'RE EXCITED. TO WORK WITH
OTHER FOLKS ON A- NARROW
SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM AND
LOVE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR OF
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND. MOMENT
PLANE. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LOUISE MONTREAT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA BE REALLY PROUD
TO BE A CO SPONSOR ON THE
SPELL- AND ENTER YOUR SUPPORT
FOR TODAY. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR. I AM EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT AFTERNOON MANY
MISSILES AND NOT A LOT- CALLING
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT THANK. LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
TODAY MY NAME IS THAT THE LACK
OF BE OCCURRING AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SHE AND
YOU PARTNERS SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME AND SAN
FRANCISCO HOUSING ACTION
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. NINE
SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WILL BE
ABLE FOR OUR IN BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I AM EIGHTY TWO. I
IN MY RECOGNIZED WITH THE DAIRY
COUNCIL HERE AT THE PORT AND
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY FIVE. IN
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VRY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER YEAH
AND I CAN ADDRESS THIS TO
EITHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE- WE DO HAVE THAT MY
DISTRICT FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO PRODUCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO I APPRECIATE THE SENTIMENT
WITH KNOWING THAT IS ANY THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
I'D SAY IT'S PROBABLY WHEN THE
LEASE CAR CONTROVERSIAL ONES IN
MY DISTRICT MY QUESTION IS
ACTUALLY REALLY PRACTICAL
QUESTION IS I THINK ONE OF THE
PRESENTER MENTION THIS
SOMETIMES FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE UNDER
UTILIZED PARKING BUT IT DOESN'T
SEEM THERE'S A REQUIREMENT IN
THE BILL TO HAVE AN ANALYSIS TO
DETERMINE THAT THAT PARKING IS
UNDER LOOT UTILIZED. IN ORDER
TO GIVE THE PARKING REDUCTION
WHAT THOUGHTS TO AND THEN WE DO
HAVE FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THEY HAVE LIMITED PARKING
AND SO IF YOU REDUCE THAT EVEN
FURTHER MY QUESTION IS WHERE
PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO GO ON DAYS
WHEN THERE ARE SIR OUT
RELIGIOUS SERVICES AND HOW IS
THAT OVERFLOW PARKING THREE
MANAGE WHEN WE'RE GIVING A
REDUCTION. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS OR
SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS ARE ONE
OF THE SPONSORS WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THURMOND SURE THIS IS A
NUMBER WHERE AND COMPLETE
COVERAGE OF IN HERE AS WELL
THAT YOU KNOW I THINK HER TO
HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR CURRENT CAN MAKE IT
INTO THEIR VIEWS- AND SO I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN- OUR
CHURCHES HAVE BUILT. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- IS THEY'VE DONE
CARPOOL LANE TODAY DONE
SHUTTLES THEY'VE DONE ALL KINDS
OF CREATIVE WAYS TO ENSURE
THAT. THEIR FOLKS CAN REACH
THEIR DOORS- AND GETTING THAT
THE SELF INTENDED TO DO THAT-
AND- WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THAT TAKING THE BERRIER AWAY
FROM ALL THE CHURCHES TO HAVE
THIS ISSUE SO THAT. WE CAN HAVE
OUR HOUSING IS I THINK OUT OVER
WAYS THE ISSUE WHERE YOU HAVE
SOME PEOPLE DON'T HAVE. THE
SPACE AND IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
TRUTH YOU CAN BUILD ON THEIR
LOT. THEY CAN IF THEY SO CHOOSE
AND THEY CAN DO SO IN A WAY
THAT THE MATTER THAT WORKS BEST
FOR THEM- IN TERMS OF. DEALING
WITH THEIR- THEIR PARTY AT
ISSUE. IS TO BRING. YOU ONE AT
THAT. WOULD YOU DATE YES BUT
WITH. FROM THE WAY. OF TAKE
PRACTICE EXPERIENCE YEAH WE HAD
THE THING THOUGHT AND I CAN
TELL YOU FROM SIR MANY COMMERCE
WITH HER ABOUT HOW THAN.
THEY'RE THE ONES BRING THAT
FOR. THANK TO ME A CHURCH THAT
WANTS TO REDUCE OR EVEN SHARE
THE PARKING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
USE ON A WEEKLY BASIS OR CLOSE
TO A WEEKLY BASIS. ALWAYS WHEN
WE'RE TALKING TO THEM ABOUT HOW
THINGS. THEY'RE MORE FOCUSED
THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER TOPIC ONE
THING WELL WE NEED THIS MUCH
PARKING WE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT MUCH PARKING IS AVAILABLE
FOR OUR FOLKS TO COME TO
CHURCH- SO. EIGHT IT YET THEY
ARE SO PROTECTIVE- AND IT'S
JUST OVER AND OVER AGAIN WE
HEAR THAT. OF THAT PARKING BUT
THEN THE AFTER THE CHURCHES WE
RUN INTO THAT HAVE PARKING THAT
THEY JUST. DON'T EVER USE ARE
THE YOU WANT THERE- EIGHTY WHY
CAN'T WE SHOW THAT PART AND
WITH RESIDENTS THE THAT WE
COULD EITHER BUILD ON THAT SOME
OF THAT. IN ORDER. ON DEVELOP
AREA SHARE THAT PARKING YEAH
THAT'S WHAT IT'S DOING ARE AND
NOW. IN AND REASON WE CAME UP
WITH THIS THE LOWEST BAY YEARS
SIMPLY TO MAKING OF CASH. IT'S
BECAUSE WITH THE A LOT OF THE
ONE AND YES REDUCE THE CHURCHES
THE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PARKING
FOR THIR USE BUT THEY ARE.
INTERESTED IN REDUCING ANY OF
THAT PARKING THAT THEY HAVE.
THANK THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL IN A FONG QUESTION- IS
THERE AN OPT IN MECHANISM SO
CITIES WHERE THEY WANT TO DO
THIS CAN OPT IN. AND A SECOND
OR THIRD QUESTION SORRY IS- IF
THE PARKING AND THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IS BEING COUNTED
TOWARDS THE RELIGIOUS. USE
PARKING DOES NOT REQUIRE THEM
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE FOR
THE BILL HOUSING ON THE SITES.
TO BE A MEMBER OF THAT
CONGREGATION OR- RELIGIOUSLY
AFFILIATED WITH THAT CHURCH A
PLACE OF WORSHIP. ALL ALL SO
THIS IMMENSELY JEFF VAN ON THE
FIRST QUESTION ANSWERED MOTORS
ARE NOT BECAUSE- CITIES COULD
EFFECTIVELY DO THAT RIGHT NOW
THEY CAN WAS NOT THE PARKING
REQUIREMENT IF THEY SEARCH
YEARS- AND DAVIS DID THAT FOR
EXAMPLE BUT IT TOOK FOUR YEARS-
SO THEY CAN EFFECTIVELY CHANGE
THEIR PARKING REQUIREMENTS TO
DATE. AND SO THERE IS NO OPTION
FOR THE BILL- AND COULD YOU
WANT TO TACKLE THE SECOND
QUESTION. I AM ABSOLUTELY THE
CASE THAT- EVERY PROJECT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST WE'VE HAD YEAH
BYE BYE FAIR HOUSING LAW%
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
DISCRIMINATION AND THAT HOUSING
BASED ON RELIGIOUS AFFILIATION-
WEEKLY A LOT OF. OUR KIDS WHO
WANT TO HELP IN SOME CASES ONE
HAVE PUBLICLY FUNDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOME CASES. GOING TO
HAVE THAT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
MEMBERS HAVE A CHANCE OF LIVING
IN SOME OF THE UNITS- BUT- THIS
IS NOT AFFILIATED WITH THE
CHURCH IN IN A WAY- YOU WERE
ASKING ABOUT- AND SO REALLY
AGAIN IT. IT ONLY SHARING
PARKING IN A WAY THAT'S REALLY
GONNA WORK FOR THE CHURCH
ASSUMING THAT THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY OVERLAP- BETWEEN
THE RESIDENT. IN THE CHURCH
GOERS SO QUESTION WITH WOULD
LOVE TO SEE SOME OF THAT
HAPPENED. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SAYING NONE OF WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE FOR SOLID DOES
SOMETHING MEMBER WORKS WITH
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- AS WELL
RESPECT LAST WE HAVE A THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS- I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU SO
MEMBER RIVAS FOR PRESENTING THE
BILL TODAY I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE FOR. THE
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
EARLY ON THE AMENDMENTS THIS
BILL WILL CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FAITH COMMUNITIES TO WORK
WITH DEVELOPERS TO PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS DO PASS AND E
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS RAMOS I
IT THREE OF US. THREE OF US I
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS I'D
VOEPEL RIGHT VOEPEL I VOTERS
EIGHT TO ZERO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I BELIEVE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY OUTSTANDING- EVERYTHING'S
OKAY I WOULD KNOW FOR THE FOR
THE BUSINESS- I'D LIKE TO JOIN
THE MEETING I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF YOU THAT CAME TODAY WITH
YOUR MASK ON AND PARTICIPATED
IN THE MEETING I KNOW THESE ARE
DIFFICULT. AND I APPRECIATE THE
TIME SO AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR.